hello oh hello professor haroche yeah
hello this is Adam Smith from Nobel
Prize to talk in Stockholm yeah we we
have this tradition of interviewing new
laureates for just a very few minutes so
may we speak thank you congratulations
on the award of the Nobel Prize thank
you very much what were you doing when
the call came when you receive the call
from Stockholm I was walking in the
street with my wife get ready to get
back home and I just caught by writer
for my poor America phone what was your
first thoughts on receiving the car my
first thought was amazement you know I
re like I think I had a thought even
before I caught the phone because I saw
the code 46 or Sweden and so I knew the
price was giving it today so I could not
believe it with the stop was my first
reaction I was really amazed and of
course it's wonderful and then I learned
about it and and it's starting to sink
in it's very take some time because
immediately after that I I was swamped
with phone calls from all over the world
and i'm still trying to recuperate from
wrappings and it's not feeling no i
think it will go on for some time but
yes yes your heartbeat must have
increased very your heart rate must have
increased very rapidly when you saw that
46 i was ready i was over when by maybe
security and I was also very glad to
share it with Dave when and when I heard
about good news because it's a he's a
friend and I admire his work very much
we have been in contact with each other
for many many years and fluids I'm very
glad to share the prize with him and in
some ways there's this lovely symmetry
about it that you trap photons and he
traps at Adam exactly exactly and and i
use atoms to study photons and he use
photos to study atoms so it's very
symmetric or under and at some point you
know during our work we published papers
back to back just by chance it happens
that we are doing similar
things on his items and my photons and
there are many similarities between now
go pansies he is also working on a very
long range project as I'm doing in Paris
with a large team of of post doc visit
our students and I'm sure he share of my
fitting buy things at this price is as
much the price of our all the colleagues
who are working with us in our groups
son house sorry we know they're all of
the Nobel Prize it has to be given to
never more than three people and so it's
very difficult to share it but I want to
stress that this is the work of two
teams which had been working very hard
with a lot of very bright people in both
dream okay again perfect symmetry
because we spoke to him earlier and he
did express exactly the same feeling
that it was all and I did not fear his
my assistant to CEO balloon told me that
you had already interviewed him but I
did not have a chance to hear he didn't
tell you and it does seem quite amazing
to think that in your laboratory you
arrange meetings between single photons
and single atoms yes we are doing that
kind of experiment and for a very long
time people who are working with huge
collections of atoms and photons and
when you work with big and sandals the
quantum properties are so to speak day
they are there hidden because of
statistical effects and if you work with
single particles as we do then you can
reveal the quantum effects in a very
dramatic way and you can learn about
these quantum processes and that's what
we are trying to do how long did it take
to build the apparatus to allow you to
do this I took a long time with the idea
which gave rise to the price started
about I would say more than 20 years ago
in all that and I'm sure the same in day
when they were moves up and it took us
many years to build the apparatus into
and to improve it to the point that we
were able to trap the photons for such a
long time so it's a very long-term
project and then I am glad that I was
working in an environment which allows
for this longer
project to be able to met you and to
flourish I was working article normal
Paris in a lab where we have a very good
students for Michael normal and from
other non-recurring primes and a lot of
postdoc and visitors for more over
Europe and all over the world it's a
very fantastic atmosphere to be able to
develop these and now I have just
changed I have moved to crash the force
which is very closed we call nomads in
Paris and there becomes the
administrator of collective hostage
which is a very important task and
that's why I do not realize very well
what's happening because I would have to
i would have to manage my administrative
task with the rizal task which will come
from the Nobel Prize and I have to
organize my life for the time being I
don't know exactly what would happen
let's hope let's hope you have a good
assistant administrator and everybody
ethical normal and accolades of us are
very happy and very very helpful and I
it's not hope everything will go away
it's nice that everyone shares in your
joy just one last question because there
is there is so much emphasis on
application application but really the
work you do it focuses on understanding
the fundamentals on understanding that
this Barrett this frontier between
classical and quantum mechanics yes
exactly and I cannot if you ask me what
would occasionally tell you I don't know
and we just tell you that I think there
will be some applications and but
whether this application would be for
the general public Oh application which
will help to improve some devices which
will be used by scientists it's not
clear to take an example of about the
work that the dev women is doing one
part of the work is to work on atomic
clocks and he's using this single the
ability to control fingers articles to
develop clogs which are fantastically
accurate and this precision could be
used to develop ways to detect very
smallest acts like small gravitational
sheet for instance so this is one
application in my work I am also using
at a big Crocs and quite different
context i use clocks which are so
sensitive to light that
can be used to detect single photons so
again there is some kind of connection
business work at nine but what would be
the use to be able to detect these
photos without destroying them I don't
know I hope that there would be some
application that they cannot I cannot
tell which but the basic research has to
come first anyway yes okay well when you
come to Stockholm in December to receive
your prize happily we have the chance to
interview both you and Dave Wineland
together we are to some again many
congratulations and thank you very much
thank you goodbye goodbye thank you